hola que tal un cordial saludo es un
gran placer estar con ustedes hoy aquí
en la represa cibernética con rufo
valencia y leonardo gimeno y bueno pues
les presentamos el castor cibernético de
este 30 de marzo en vivo y en directo en
facebook live youtube y en nuestro sitio
rcn un caluroso saludo a todas y todos
gracias por su amable compañía y les
deseamos a todos los creyentes que nos
están escuchando y oyendo en este
momento una feliz semana santa viernes
de crucifixión
así que ruffo leonato bienvenidos
gracias gracias de cerca sí y tenemos
como se han dado cuenta tenemos visita
aquí en el estudio se trata de el imán
hassan guille bienvenido al castor
cibernético imán a zhang y muchas
gracias de invitarme
la misma cosa buena semana feliz semana
santa a todas las gentes a toda la gente
que escuchan que pienso que es una buena
ocasión de albergó un imán con vosotros
para la semana santa
muchas gracias de invitarme como
solamente quiero
tengo un poco de miedo de verme
falsificado hoy
no se preocupe por eso y bueno con él y
mamá a zhang y llevamos a hablar sobre
este reconocimiento de culpabilidad de
alexandre bissonette autor del atentado
contra el centro cultural islámico de
quebec que que dejó seis muertos y seis
heridos el 29 de enero del 2017 y bueno
y de lo que representa esta confesión de
culpabilidad para la comunidad musulmana
vamos a hablar pero antes de entrar en
materia
de entrar en el grano de ir al grano
vamos como de costumbre
a evocar ver si hay algo que haya
llamado su atención esta semana alguna
noticia algo insólito pero hoy es el
regreso de alguna forma a las salas
prácticas de la guerra fría con este
ping-pong de diplomáticos expulsados lo
interesante es justamente ver como
inglaterra por ejemplo de la gran
bretaña logra mediante este este del
mega drama de del supuesto
envenenamiento con gases tóxicos de una
ex espía de la cía y su hija como ese
escándalo logra tapar el fraude mayor y
de mayor consecuencia que es el que fue
la manipulación de los resultados del
brics it y que además pone sobre la mesa
de la mesa el hecho de que se trata de
una compañía de manipulación
manipulación porque esa es la palabra de
datos de información e inclusive si coso
métrica
que se ha llevado a cabo en 200
selecciones en distintos lugares del
mundo incluyendo méxico argentina en
colombia brasil está investigando es
decir que estamos frente al cadáver de
la democracia tal como la conocemos y
todo y todo el mundo contento expulsando
diplomáticos y los medios de
comunicación contentos de que cada
expulsa solidaridad y vuelve el lenguaje
absurdo de la segunda guerra mundial
países aliados aliados a quien a una a
una mafia que manipula democracia por
dios si leonardo si no a mí me llama la
atención que a partir de este de esta
historia de cambridge analítica la gente
ha decidido ha empezado a alejarse de
las redes sociales como si fuera la
solución o sea que hay un decrecimiento
de la gente primero de los abonos y
segundo de gente que se está yendo como
si cerrar una cuenta fuera impedir que
esta gente nos investigue o
vigilados como estas sabemos que pasa
hace muchísimo tiempo y aparte no
solamente las redes sociales social los
bancos el mail lo seguimos utilizando
las el consumo del internet en en la
casa en los teléfonos todo eso está está
mirado desde cerca por las autoridades
de distintos países el hecho y por los
espías que están escuchando ahora es
decir que a mí el dato que siempre me
llama la atención creo que la discreción
ha pasado y lo vuelvo a decir que que el
dueño de facebook cuando le hacen un
reportaje y tiene su computador tiene
tapada la cámara
es por algo
que sabe y tiene tapada la cámara con
una cinta para que su ordenador si es
jaqueado no se lo vea realmente es de
temerse y me parece graciosa la
respuesta de la gente temerosa por lo
que puede pasar por lo que compartió en
facebook hace años que andan
compartiendo hoy comí esto mañana como
aquello estoy entre nadal argumenta el
lugar me voy de viaje foto conmigo se
mueven todo todo todo más lo ahora se
descubrió que hasta en los likes en
distintas cosas pueden realmente cerrar
digamos la tendencia política o social
de una persona entonces y ahora cierran
las cuentas como si fuera el skate me
voy cierra la puerta y borrones cuenta
nueva no no no no no es más si uno borra
en la cuenta de facebook no se va o sea
sigue estando toda esa información ahí
arriba durante no sé cuánto tiempo así
que a la gente que no se ponga paranoica
para evitar ese tipo de cosas hay que ir
a vivirse con un ermitaño y no tener
ningún tipo de comunicación y creo que
ni siquiera así ni siquiera hemos
escapado y bueno entonces estamos en un
callejón sin salida desafortunadamente
los medios en las redes sociales existen
que ahí están nos internamos por ese
camino y no hay porque aparte no sólo
son las redes sociales a eso iba o sea
la gente tiene cuentas bancarias tiene
perfiles de en el médico tiene perfiles
de las clínicas que tienen perfiles en
los clubes cuando uno se asocia tiene
perfil foto todo sea este todo ahí claro
esto es básicamente como ser atropellado
por un auto y lamentarse por la
invención de la rueda claro por ejemplo
voy a agarrar al vuelo es sólo del auto
porque bueno lo mío es más ligero menos
pensado
lo insólito es algo que vi justamente en
las redes sociales esta semana en la que
había un anuncio que decía durante la
semana santa sea prudente cuando
conduzca porque usted no resucitará el
domingo
y hablando justamente de ese tipo de
signos hay otro que en un libro
veía por ahí decía que los anuncios en
la india de seguros drive like hell and
you get there
[Risas]
bueno y otro otra noticia hace un poco
insólita que me llamó la atención que vi
por ahi esta semana es que los pasajeros
unos pasajeros que venían de europa en
la compañía en la línea aérea islandesa
guau y llegaron aquí a montreal
estuvieron en la pista durante horas
porque porque descubrieron hormigas en
el avión entonces
[Risas]
las hormigas también tenían una
infestación de hormigas entonces tenían
que analizar las hormigas y ver que no
representaban un peligro en fin la gente
pasó varias horas en la pista de acá del
aeropuerto internacional de montreal
porque las hormiguitas vinieron a
engañarles
e indocumentadas
yo no sé si tiene algo así inédito o
algo que le haya llamado la atención
esta semana como noticia aparte del tema
que vamos a tocar después no de esta
semana yo estaba muy ocupado por el
suscripto para ver cuál estoy aquí la
cuestión de
de la declaración de culpabilidad de
alexander visión no tenía mucho tiempo
para ver otras horas
esta vez estaba con periodistas como
ustedes gente de la comunidad
analizando hablando preparando la gente
con eso no tenía mucho tiempo para otras
cosas pero en alguna cosa concreta es
que ahora digamos en la vida doméstica
cuando hay discrepancias con la
compañera o el compañero entonces ya no
se puede decir no me comprendes porque
todo quien está compañero a compañeros
ver en google para comprender a la
persona sí sí
así de fácil y bueno ya estamos en
semana santa
entonces estamos con acompañados acá por
el imán hassan aquí y bueno y imán
existe el equivalente de la semana santa
en el islam no la semana santa la semana
santa en islam no pero los musulmanes
tienen dos fiestas una al fin del mes
sagrado de ramadán
1 a las fiestas y se llama del
sacrificio
dos meses diez días después la fin de
rábano
decíamos que para ahorita fuera de
micrófono decíamos que para los
cristianos hoy es el viernes santo pero
que para el islam todos los viernes
todos los viernes son los son santas
bueno y con este año también coincide el
pesaj judío con la semana santa de hoy
empiezan también también el pez access
si la semana santa se recuerda la
crucifixión de cristo en isla ambas se
conmemora la muerte del profeta si no
primero para hablarte de jesús para los
musulmanes jesús es una profeta como
como mamá y mamá como muy muy muchísimos
es ibiza mujer
abraham todos los profetas en la biblia
son propiedad en islam incluyo e incluso
el jesús la diferencia entre la religión
musulmana y la cristiana la relación
cristiana es el cristianismo se dice que
jesús fue crucificado al recitarle
crucificado hoy y necesitada el 2000
domingo
pero para nosotros diríamos que él no
estaba crucificado porque antes la
crucificación dios
el salvado antes la clasificación y
hasta ahora para nosotros jesús no fue
muerte
es una otra persona que que tenía más o
menos como se dice recibe son los que
tenía una otra persona que fue cultivado
en lugar de jesús porque jesús como es
una profeta como es un nacido con la
concedida es el espíritu santo no es
posible identificar ni de matar a sí
mismo exactamente si lo interesante o
sea que hubo un doble en algún lugar
segundo exactamente para los cristianos
volvió para los gobiernos un nuevo yo
nunca nunca exacto ése es el tema no ha
vuelto todavía no ha vuelto a la reunión
una
bueno hay la idea del regreso de caminar
una una parte dentro del judaísmo que
justamente está esperando el segundo es
un regreso para ccoo como ha estado que
la cada mujer judía cuando tiene un
nuevo hijo espera todo el tiempo que él
va a estar el mes y que ellos hasta
ahora esperan la llegada de mi tía pero
para nosotros el mesías o jesús estaba
con nosotros
he venido vivió en la tierra más el
mismo tiempo como se dice los cristianos
la diferencia la clasificación
no creemos en la clasificación creemos
que como el espíritu santo fue
directamente
bueno para beneficio de las personas que
nos están escuchando en este momento
hassan guille
qué es un imán o sea para los que no
saben qué es un imán quieren quién puede
hacer el trabajo del imán quién puede
ser imán o que el imán en hisham es el
imán es una palabra árabe que es decir
las personas pero enfrente el imanes
tienen muchas posibles
cosas que pueda que hace el dirigirla
como si de elaboración la plegaria la
oración
dirige la oración dirige el down es un
guía espiritual para la gente ésta es el
vuelo de lima que es quien puede estar
imán
todo el tiempo todo el mundo cualquier
persona pero pero hay calificaciones si
hay dos personas juntos que deben
hacerla la elaboración uno debe estar el
imam si vemos aquí cuatro vamos a elegir
uno de nosotros para hacer el imán como
soy el sol solo musulmán pienso que voy
a extrañar
[Risas]
con eso que cada vez que hay un grupo de
personas 234 van a elegir uno de ellos
para este animal
pero oficialmente cuando hay una
mezquita o un grupo muy grande y muy
formal
el imán tiene que tiene una formación
en religión tiene a conocer el corán o
tiene a conocer la la vida del profeta
tiene a conocer el árabe tiene a ver una
buena voz para recitar el corán o una
buena conducta todas estas cosas aunque
puede ser cualquiera pero también hay
condiciones condiciones en el mundo
musulmán
ahora hay universidades que forman y
maps
y el estado elige y manos para en pie
como se permita es no para para pilar
para porque no hay exageraciones porque
como cada uno puede estar y mar
hemos visto cómo se dice en francés auto
proclama o auto programa dos
autoproclamados con ideología más o
menos integristas más o menos
con todas formas de ideas en los estados
para controlar esos dirigentes son como
se dice funcionarios del estado
en todo el mundo musulmán de todo el
mundo musulmán del mundo católico
también en china por ejemplo son las
autoridades chinas las que decimos los
obispos y si hay algún comentario o
leonardo si los comentarios
ismael zamora bueno comparte nuestro
youtube para que la gente no pueda
seguir también desde ahí
guil en abril dice saludos de la
multicolor ciudad de guanajuato estoy
disfrutando de su preciosa laberinto que
tejones de sus edificios barrocos y sus
plazas coloniales el lunes empieza en mi
inmersión lingüística en la escuela don
quijote felices vascos para todos smile
zamora dice saludos desde salvatierra
guanajuato méxico y jon y willy navarro
feliz semana santa para todos los
oyentes drs y canadá las américas en
todo el mundo mi abrazo amistoso desde
perú donde las celebraciones religiosas
se desarrollan en todo el país de la
mejor manera
renato méndez agnès nos pone una carita
con un corazón así que está contento de
estar con nosotros y lucy pib y dice
hola de lucia de grande españa pero soy
quebequense de montreal y se nos está
escuchando desde antes de todo bueno y
ahora sí vamos a conversar sobre el caso
de alexandre visones y manhattan guille
vamos a hacer una recapitulación para
que los que no estén al tanto sepan de
qué estamos
el 29 de enero del 2017 alexandre vision
& aunque ve que sea un joven quebequense
entró armado al centro cultural islámico
de la ciudad de québec abrió el fuego y
mató a seis personas e hirió a seis
personas más su juicio comenzó el lunes
de esta semana aquí en montreal contra
el pesan seis acusaciones de homicidio
premeditado al principio del juicio el
se declaró no culpable pero al regreso
de la pausa del mediodía se sorprendió
al juez declarándose culpable de las
acusaciones que pesan sobre él bueno eso
es muy resumido y manhattan guille
qué significa ese reconocimiento de
culpabilidad de alexandre visiones para
usted para que para comenzar y para la
comunidad musulmana no solamente para la
comunidad misional puedo decir para la
sociedad quebequense en totalidad
como sabemos es vivimos aquí en un
estado de derecho cada persona que
conoce dice presunta inocente hasta que
alguna prueba de que enfrente el corte
que es culpable es decir que elección
del buzón es y no ha declarado si no ha
reconocido su culpabilidad
es decir que el corte debía hacer el
proceso para proveer para probar que el
gran gol para que quiera culpable que es
decir que la gente las víctimas
los virus las viudas los huérfanos los
heridos
la persona que es discapacitado en el
atentado
es decir que toda esta gente debía venir
al corte para vivir de nuevo todo el
dolor en la suficiencia que han vivido
el 29 de enero la nueva edición de 2010
2017 hasta ahora con este deber con este
declaración de culpabilidad por lo menos
están estas personas pueden es empezar a
vivir sus luto minutos en serenidad y
paz
esta es la primera cosa la segunda cosa
es muy importante para todos nosotros no
solamente como musulmanes como que bien
sé que pienses como canadienses
nuestro ente interés de saber por qué la
lección de lo que ha hecho el 29 de
enero porque no podemos hacer nada para
ayudar las muertes de los muertos nada
que podemos hacer que va a dar a un
huérfano su padre oa una viuda a su
marido pero por lo menos debemos saber
por qué
la lección de vision & ha cometido su
crimen el 29 de enero para tratar de
proteger otra gente porque si si si hay
un proceso de radicalización un proceso
de odio un proceso de propaganda de
propaganda de odio que ha efectuado
alexander y la
él ha transformado entre una persona que
quiere vivir y dejar vivir en un asesino
debemos conocer que ese proceso proceso
para proteger la gente espero realizando
versiones de esta última víctima que
desea tener novia si desea tratar robo
tú tienes alguna pregunta en particular
pues justamente quiero destacar esto de
que justamente el proceso de formación
de estas ideas y tengo acá por ejemplo
el tratamiento mediático que se hace
entre las redes inglesas y francesas en
que no sé cuál es su cuál es su análisis
porque veo qué
dentro de los medios francófonos digamos
que hay un poco más de quizás de temor
de ir a buscar justamente los elementos
constituyentes de esa forma de pensar
entonces cuál es su lectura de trabajo
de los medios de comunicación en la
exploración de las causas de este tipo
de acciones hay muchas tendencias hay
una tendencia que dice que miran al el
solo autor esa elección de visiones no
debemos mirar
afuera de exxon de vision & todo el todo
el líquido y vamos a hacer es juzgar a
elección de emisiones
y después de ese extenso discurso van a
decir mira no es una persona frágil es
una persona que tenía problemas mentales
mentales que es una persona que sí es
decir que no hay no hay ninguna persona
que puede estar responsable yo digo no
primero no pienso que la elección de
personal él es el único culpable
en la prueba que después que el 29 antes
del 29 de enero y después
y hemos visto muchas cosas cómo se dice
como se dice de la propaganda de odio
que la mezquita de quebec la misma
mezquita de que vergara / letras de odio
y había muchas mezquitas a través del
que ve que fui a conseguir vandalizado
había la campaña de temor la campaña de
odio cuando hemos tratado de establecer
un cementario musulmán en la en santa
teresa santa apolinar había el coche del
señor la vida el presidente del consejo
de la mezquita de quebec la misma
mezquita que a que estaba el teatro de
la tragedia del 29 de enero y todas esas
cosas
estaban cuando alexander visiones estaba
en prisión
porque es decir que hay otras personas
en la sociedad que tratan de insidiar
y destruir de destruirse de destruir
nuestro paz social hay más al ex hombre
exactamente no solamente en la provincia
en todo el mundo
no podemos hacer mucho cuerpo por lo que
pasa en áfrica or en europa pero podemos
hacer algo para lo que se pasa aquí en
quebec por eso digo
con
con lucha como se dice
a fuerzas que tenemos debemos buscar las
respuestas debemos entender lo que ha
pasado lo que ha estaba en la cabeza de
alexander millones de quien ha propuesto
ha propuesto de resoluciones joel como
he dicho el 3 de febrero el año pasado
antes de plantear
antes de matar sus víctimas hay ideas
más peligrosas que los bala que las
balas quien fue plantada en su cabeza
si yo creo que la historia pasa por si
esta persona cualquier persona que tenga
un problema mental
puede lamentablemente podría
desencadenar una situación de violencia
ok pero el tema es porque el
ensañamiento con la comunidad musulmana
porque a una mezquita porque no de
vuelta se fue a una bomba es exacto o
sea evidentemente hay algo más que
empujó a esta persona a hacer ese cuerpo
de mira a él en su declaración en frente
del corte el viernes el miércoles piensa
el 29 el 20 y el 28 ha declarado que yo
no soy terrorista exacto
yo no soy y se mofó porque lo que usted
ha hecho 11 de busti
[Risas]
si usted no es
terrorista porque has matado
todas estas gentes inocentes primero
segundo él decía que tenía muchas ideas
suicidas aunque si una persona quiere
suicidarse va a tirar una bala en la
cabeza
porque matar toda la gente él es vivo
en vida y las otras no es sino esta
islamofobia
como nuestro amigo aquí ha dicho porque
en una mezquita porque no hay un centro
comercial y un club
un park
y hace no sólo el el net no conocía es
tangente la sola cosa quiere que que es
común a esta gente son musulmanas hacen
la oración en una mezquita dentro dentro
de hay dos digamos por venta y dos
aspectos en esta en esta frase está más
allá de sus consecuencias y este juicio
por un lado está la consideración
fundamentalmente religiosa del perdón
que pues que tiene su forma de
funcionamiento que es una herramienta
fundamental en las religiones del texto
sí pero por otro lado estamos también
ante un una s una un escenario político
porque es el hecho de que la mañana se
declara no culpable al mediodía vuelve
siendo culpable cuáles son
tomando en cuenta por ejemplo que el
debate sobre el velo fue un debate que
alcanzó a
a las lecciones en la provincia y
tomando en cuenta que estamos también en
un año de elecciones provinciales
como que como con ser usted que va a ser
utilizado para bien o para mal este este
juicio
porque voy a hablar tú has hablado de
hablar de dos cosas el perdón y la
ramificación política voy a hablar del
partido en nuestra organización como él
el cristianismo también hay el concepto
de perdón pero hay condiciones del
perdón y la primera condición es que la
persona reconoce lo que he hecho desde
la pérdida de defendida y toma la
decisión solo en el que no va a regresar
no va a hacerlo de nuevo
nuevamente aquí lo que
ha hecho en el corte que es un buen paso
se dice que en la buena dirección con
esto podemos empezar a 10 que son
ampliamente podemos decir que él
reconoce su culpabilidad
tenemos que conocer sobre mí que el
reconocimiento solamente práctica por
para para tener buen como se dice una
pena menos grave no grave o va porque
exactamente el ciencia la mente se
conoce el mal que ha hecho aquí el
tiempo para decirlo y para con para para
conceder convencernos de su cita
sinceridad hay otros pasos que que éste
el joven deberá hacer el primero
ayudarnos a entender lo que pasa no
esta palabra esta declaración general
que a tenía ideas negras tenía ideas
suicidas no no no soy terrorista ni soy
islamofobia es no no no es suficiente
falta la sinceridad le falta a la
realidad
ayer pienso me han pedido en la
televisión él dice que no es termina el
respeto no he visto nunca un terrorista
que declara que se dice terrorista todo
esto exterior los terroristas se dicen
que somos que luchamos para una buena
cosa para la libertad para dios para sí
para eso no hay una persona que va a
decir estoy yo soy terrorista
realizó divisiones para empezar el
proceso del perdón
tiene que estar franca con su mismo y
con nosotros con su familia y quienes
con su creador también
para el proceso político tengo miedo voy
a estar honesta con ustedes tengo miedo
en este
como se dice escenario escenario
electoral que hay gente que van a tratar
de usar lo que ha pasado pero hasta
ahora no lo he visto como hemos visto en
la misma cosa en 2014 2014 2012 las
cosas estaban muy claro el 2015 con el
elección federal las elecciones
federales
ahora hasta ahora el el tema
el tema de islam o anti islám no es
usado
de manera exagerada espero que vamos a
continuar
en ese paso porque no va a ayudar
ninguna persona
que degustar una comunidad
como skateboard como sedición o
escritorio para ganar las elecciones
hasta nos somos todos ciudadanos de este
país de este país somos tenemos todas
las mismas derechas de derechos también
derechos también debemos vivir juntos en
ninguna
persona política o en la media debe
tener la libertad de usar una comida
contra la otra y para su propio
beneficio
leonardo tienes por ahí algún comentario
manuel martínez o mrt z supongo que es
la abreviatura de martínez dice saludos
un mensaje se basta con el genocidio que
hay en venezuela y lucy pibe dice pienso
que las causas posibles y supongo que
está hablando del tema que está hablando
el imán con nosotros dice que son el
miedo y la ignorancia social y la
ignorancia del otro entre otros
problemas sí de acuerdo muy bien esos
son los comentarios de nuestros oyentes
el tiempo está pasando rapidísimo vamos
a hacer una pequeña pausa y vamos a ver
con los temas que resaltamos esta semana
tú rufo tú nos hablas del papá francisco
y de las escuelas residenciales en
canadá así justamente el año pasado el
primer ministro en todo estuvo en el
tuvo una reunión con el papá francisco y
le pidió personalmente que presente sus
disculpas a los pueblos indígenas
canadienses por
por el trato recibido por los indígenas
a través de más de un siglo de
existencia de las escuelas residenciales
para los indígenas estas escuelas
esenciales fueron un acto de genocidio
cultural porque de lo que se trataba era
de arrancar a los niños de las
comunidades indígenas ponerlos en
escuelas voluntariamente construidas lo
más lejos posible de sus lugares lugares
de vida para las consecuencias y el soto
para matar a los indígenas para matar a
indígenas niño y hacerlo entre comillas
europeo ha ostentado civilizado entonces
el papá respondió indicando a través de
los obispos de canadá que no da esa
disculpa lo cual ha hecho que líderes
como él en gamer por ejemplo que es una
importante líder indígena mohawk declaró
que el papá no está tomando la
responsabilidad que el lector que le
corresponde por ese por esos actos
entonces ese digamos el tema y además el
tronco estar dice también que quien mal
tino del papá de justamente escoger las
semanas
que es justamente a la semana de la
contrición porque esta noche es cuando
jesús lava los pies a los a sus
discípulos en señal de humildad es
justamente esta semana que él decidió
justamente responder con un no al pedido
de los indígenas canadienses en rcn
punto o sea si ustedes quieren tener más
detalles
leonardo tú nos presentas a family link
que es una aplicación para monitorear
los celulares de los menores así es esa
función hasta los 13 años es bastante
simple es súper interesante porque uno
puede monitorear absolutamente todo lo
que pasa dentro de un dispositivo que
tenga una criatura un niño hasta 13 años
uno generando una cuenta de google está
esta aplicación es de google que la
instala en los dispositivos de los niños
los niños no la pueden desinstalar hasta
que el padre no las des instale y puede
controlar y cortarle el acceso a
internet ver las cosas que accede poner
filtros para las búsquedas en internet y
en youtube así que es súper interesante
y hay un dato muy interesante también es
que en la promoción de esta aplicación
que se instale
dice que está disponible en canadá en
estados unidos en méxico en 9% perú en
argentina en chile la instaló yo aquí en
canadá y me hice country not supported
caramba entonces llamó al servicio
técnico de google mentalidad chateo con
el servicio técnico de google y el
técnico el servicio técnico de google me
dice pero usted dónde está en canadá
pero donde en montreal a esos en que ve
que no está todavía somos otro país
somos otro país para google
canadá de quebec es otro país así que
los independentistas deben estar muy
contentos
pienso que hay muchas personas que van a
estar contentas recuperar las elecciones
google nos reconoce como país bueno muy
bien yo por mi parte los invito a
escuchar una entrevista que hice con una
fotógrafa que me 15 que se dedica
estudió fotorreportaje fotoperiodismo y
ella está
digamos utiliza la fotografía para
representar la belleza de otra forma
entonces ella fotografía a personas
mayores de 70 años entre 70 y 100 años
así que esta es en su proyecto de
fotografía y es muy interesante ahora se
está preparando va a presentar una
exposición dentro de poco y entre otras
cosas
ella va a visitar para completar este
retrato de las personas mayores va a
visitar las zonas azules no sé si les
dice algo las zonas azules las zonas
azules son lugares geográficamente
reconocidos y científicamente
reconocidos por porque son lugares donde
la gente vive es más longeva sean vive
más tiempo hay más gente mayor en esas
zonas azules hay 5 zonas azules en el
planeta está una en la isla de okinawa
esta otra
loma linda califórnia en la península de
nicoya en costa rica en la isla de
icaria en grecia y ella estuvo
recientemente en cerdeña entonces la
idea de ella en su proyecto es viajar a
esas ciudades para tomar las fotos de
los ancianos que viven allí corriendo
ahí en pantalla algunas de las fotos que
son realmente exquisitas de esa es la
programa y ahí vamos a pasar a ver
algunas de las fotos que muestra en el
álbum son realmente extraordinarias
estamos acá si no me equivoco tiene 102
años 112
ella tiene 102 años sí sí
es realmente muy bonito el trabajo así
que les recomiendo que vayan a ver esta
exposición en realidad que lean el
artículo el artículo ideal no que es un
poco osada son fotos de de semidesnudas
y de desnudo porque ya dice de que los
ancianos también pueden mostrarse sí sí
si quieren no entonces psc sus desafíos
de convencer a la gente para su
exposición r6 net punto sea para que
vayan a visitar nuestro sitio y bueno ya
nos queda muy poco tiempo que podemos
decir en conclusión hassan muy
rápidamente sobre este juicio que ya
comenzó de alexandre visiones aquí en
montreal el resumen no podemos hacer
mucho para la gente a la gente que han
perdido la vida pero debemos hacer algo
para proteger la gente que están ahora
en vida
nuestros
hijos e hijas en la sociedad en general
necesita y me dice una buena protección
por eso pido a señalar que son
divisiones de ayudarnos y hablar de que
es el proceso es que la jugó aquí que la
ha ayudado a hacer lo que ha hecho para
proteger a los demás
porque para para tratar que está la sala
la última víctima de violencia e
ignorancia en este sucesor citó muy bien
determinar tengo 13 participaciones
micro-sim rovira nos dice hola amigos de
canadá las américas café os veo y
escucho desde mi segunda residencia en
calafell en el ex
baic sepan es no sé cómo se dice supongo
que es catalán en tarragona españa
pasando las vacaciones de semana santa
un fuerte abrazo y muchos 73 luis
balderas dice escuchando y viendo de san
antonio en chile saludos agua y javier
gonzález nungaray nuestro taxista
preferido
nos dice antes de que termine el
programa saludos a todos y al invitado
así que y bueno pues entonces
agradecemos inmensamente al imán hassan
guille por haberse desplazado este
viernes santo el dejo su plegaria allá
en donde donde vive pero la va a retomar
en una mezquita cerca de a cadenas hace
muchas gracias estoy muy feliz que no
estaba criticado gracias y yo les
recuerdo que la versión con audio de
este programa la pueden escuchar hoy
mismo en nuestro sitio internet la
música estará a cargo de la colombo
canadiense jessica reyes que acaba
el premio y uno de revelación del año y
bueno eso fue todo y no nos podemos
despedir sin saludar al prisma y a la
gente que nos mira
muchísimas gracias